I'll talk about 70 pin tricks on how to
make the most of your Cuba night is
joining okay so you might be starting
with Cuban 80s or you know you barely
experienced and there are few tip and
six that I want to share with you today
so the first one which I'm going to show
you which I'm going to share with you
today is to actually take it easy so you
might you might have used other tools in
the past to deploy your application or
so just to scale them and then most of
them you know they are okay they are
complex to to start with but sort of
sort of towards the middle you start
mastering them and you become an expert
when it comes to Cuban 80's CUNA's
easily be more complicated than anything
else you've tried before and then as
soon as you start deploying it things
become increasingly complex until they
become impossibly complex and and even
if you must have things such as you know
network policies or for disruption
budgets you might find yourself falling
off the cliff
so first tip is take it easy it takes
time to learn Cuba natives you cannot
learn CUNA's in three hours okay that's
just not doable and not even you know in
a weekend the second tip I've got for
you is you'll find yourself typing the
same thing over and over again okay
that's very very common so you know the
way we get part of the deployment
usually is by typing a command line so
what if I can also complete that what if
I can amend my productivity by using
things such as cube CTL auto-completion
or by mastering how to navigate the
documentation by using the CLI okay that
a project like cube context and cube
namespace or you can easily switch
context and namespaces in Cuban eighties
there is a very interesting plugin
called an interesting plug-in manager
called crew and way in which you can
install new plugins from cube city el
and extend how cube CTL works and then
there are also project like ups one
where you can have a nice prompt of the
current context in your terminal okay so
all of those if you're interested the
kind of stuff I think I just posted a
couple of links and those dive a little
bit more into how you can optimize your
productivity when it
when it comes to cuban natives the the
first tip i've got for you is a done
drop connection so this is so so so
common that we get questions all the
time so what happens is if you're
familiar with kubernetes but even if
you're not familiar with cuba natives
what you will find is that cuban
eighties every time you are prayed a
version of your application it will do
what's called a rolling deployment so
wouldn't brite bring up a new version of
the application and then will replace it
with the previous one and it will do the
same for all the applications inside
your cluster but replacing an
application means that we need to know
when up their application can receive
connections if my application takes and
may need to start what happens if I
replace it with a new version and I just
start in a custom next one right that's
actually that that sort of behavior is
controlled with something called
liveness and readiness probes so those
are crucial so when you do a rolling
update cuba ladies will wait for
aliveness and readiness probe before
he's going to move on to the next one so
if you don't put those ones in it's very
very easy to take down your production
infrastructure ok so my tip for you is
just check your liveness and readiness
for every right and make sure that work
the first tip i've got today is click
and play so you might be tempted to use
GCP right just click on the UI create a
project click on Jiki gke create create
a cluster just select number of nodes
the type of nodes and then click on
connect and and connect to the cluster
right and then if you are an e KS so
these amazon offering you might do the
same right you might login in consult in
AWS and just click on a couple of
buttons and create a cluster if you are
a your fun same thing right but all of
these are good when you're getting
started but if you're building
production infrastructure that's not
necessarily the best way to approach
things the reason is quite simple if you
start clicking the UI it's very hard to
synchronize the changes across
environments if you want to create a new
environments you need to copy and paste
the same values
do I have two tabs open in my browser
just coping the values in and out and it
takes a lot of time to do it I still
need to go and click every single page
and just go through making sure that I
haven't missed anything right so rather
than doing that my suggestion would be
just look at something like
infrastructure is code so terraforming
is a good example of that but also
projects such as bloomie are pioneering
in in what you can do when it comes to
creating your own cluster as code so you
write to leave the code and you say
create and that will what it will that
look like it's like this right I go
inside a folder called add I do a
terraform apply that it brings up ten
nodes for my cluster I want to do that
in prod I switch into a different folder
there is a different set of
configuration using the same code I
create another cluster tip number five
know how to expose your services or so
most of the time in Cuban eighties and
and and Hunter just describe our
services and port works in Cuban
eighties most of the time what we have
is an internal load balancer which
distributed traffic to our applications
when we have multiple services right we
need to find a way to distribute this
traffic I'm gonna across all of these
internal load balancers so what do we do
we bring another load balancer on top
which does the load distribution but
this load balancer it comes in all sort
of flavors you could use nginx
you could use H proxy proxy you could
use glue sto citrix you can use Kong
ambassador which one is the right one
for me well it's really really hard but
project like this from cube tanks gives
you a good idea or corner of what kind
of options you have when it comes to
selecting and ingress for example not
all the ingress have things such as
being working across the cluster so for
example Congress doesn't write these are
not pending space spaces so project like
this that are really really useful so
the tip number six is automatic OVA
Nance so you if you build if you're
building a cluster or just using a
cluster as part of a team particularly
if you're talking about very large teams
in the under
in the range of hundreds of thousands
what you will see is that there is a
need to validate these resources that
you submitted to the cluster so this
llaman files so ideally you want to
validate them you want to make sure that
all of the developers or all of your
colleagues are using the same images the
same structure the same labels so you
want to standardize what the Amalie is
and ideally you want to catch the error
earlier right so we don't want to let
anyone publish anything to the cluster
which is not what what is supposed to be
so if you have any of these sort of
challenges the solution is to use
something like the open policy agent we
can define things such as I only want
this container to be published in my
cluster reject all the other containers
or you can look at a project called
copper from classic 66 which is
basically just a validator for llamó
and a very similar one is cubivore from
instrumental they are designed as you
can see here they are designed to
basically just look at a young files and
run some sort of linting so you know if
your resources I'm good so the last tip
I've got for today
for you today and so the best way to
make the most of your kubernetes journey
is to actually enjoy the journey so I
was lucky enough to be in cube combust
Alana earlier this year and I had the
opportunity to meet a lot of people that
I will normally only meet online so I
think that really made a difference for
me so that was everything I wanted to
show you today my name is Daniele I work
for a company called Larry kubernetes
thank you very much
so so the so the talk that I presented
lasted five minutes when I presented it
a cube Kanchana okay so I was a cube con
China and I was lucky enough to be a
cube comparsa learner and as you can
imagine they were like loads of places
with vendors and stickers so what I did
I know that not everyone is lucky as me
and can go to conferences across the
globe and just collect stickers so I
collected the stickers for you so if you
haven't had the opportunity to go to
cube Khan the opportunities is actually
right there you can go and collect any
stickers you want I only ask you to be
mindful of others though so just don't
go there and grab all the stickers just
make sure you share them with others
okay there's only another things I
wanted to say and I'm done so we what we
do is a company we do training for Cuba
natives so we just released a free
course on Cuban 80 so everything that
hunter just explained you can try on on
our mini course you can just take an
application and just deploy it in Cuban
it is the application that you will
develop is a notetaking application so
these course guides you from building
the application and deploying it so this
first part is actually building it and
then you learn how to package it out in
docker containers
hopefully this is a video
and then the other part is actually
deploying in inside kubernetes and this
goes and explain how to do that the
application is built in such a way that
you understand how storage works so this
one used meteor which is as free
compatible sort of storage engine and
then it goes with girls dive into how to
deploy these in PKS which is the Amazon
offering so if you want to have a look
this is all completely free and it's
going to guide you through how to do the
deployment and how to try it just go to
this URL and that's it thank you very
much
[Applause]